caught you
in 420p 420p
yep yep we got him today we're checking
out people [ __ ] in 4k that's the meme at
least i don't get it close your door
next time
what kind of demon is that
we've all done this i actually do it all
the time check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
it's normal it's part of growing up
she's going to um
why is it so hard to pull the goddamn
handbrake a handbrake is a big problem
for people what am i looking at there's
something blocking there's a guy chasing
a dog as what
oh this is it's a treadmill it's from
there it's from their gym
and the tongue escape and the deck is oh
god
the mom just rides into
what a wonderful clip oh i needed that i
needed a good movie night with friends
[Music]
like
what
what
people take photos snap photos of me and
thinking i don't see them but it's
always like this
[Music]
are you
and people think i'm awkward huh so this
woman caught stealing a 24 case of beer
under her dress
it's not super heavy that's super heavy
how is she holding that
oh my god how is she so casually walking
like that woman steals good from store
by hiding it this seems to be a common
theme oh my god
[Music]
store manager asks to check her goods
gets canceled
he's [ __ ] going for it damn girl
chill i can't even see it
jason she's getting toothpaste that was
hot that's what you have to say about
that really
she's just
tv
a [ __ ] tv
how women fit
stop
how do they walk so normal
damn i underestimate women i gotta say
she plainly done this before i think i
found the weirdest
rabbit hole of celebrities caught
farting you're about to watch hillary
clinton saying that that's really part
of a larger pattern with you that you
look at that face that's a woman about
this
you often avoid taking firm positions on
controversial issues
and she didn't become president i can't
believe it
[Laughter]
i am very confused by this v sauce
posted this nine years ago five years
ago when i was in college i made this
and ben reyes creator of barely
political and the key of awesome saw
these videos and hired me
a few years later i started vsauce this
is visa's first channel this is the
weirdest origin story hillary clinton
farts i'm actually curious about actual
celebrities farting there has to be
there's a taylor swift part or did she
must investigate starring scott eastwood
here's the video
[Laughter]
how did mike pick that up i need the
science behind this
there was you notice there's a slight
delay in the farm which you might
because the sound of the part is going
downwards
uh which delays the sound kind of like
when an ambulance hit you from a long
distance it changes the frequency of
design weights and that's why it takes a
while for even though she bends down the
farm it takes a while for us to hear it
because sound travels slower than light
[Applause]
so therefore i have a conclusion
we have some intellectuals in the
comments i must have ripped one at some
point oh yeah yeah okay
what what don't fail
cut to me saying i really think i
matured now i think my audience and i
we've become more mature over the years
so it's funnier because i hide and she
doesn't see that i
stared at myself
catching people farting with a thermal
camera
not this is a fake one
i've seen this
[Music]
although those pugs will 100 fart
[Music]
did you guys hear that that's so loud i
could only smell it before we continue
quick word from sponsored you're not
using norwegian
protect yourself by browsing online
safely and securely with nordvpn.com
pewdiepie use the link no code you
already know why you should use a
nordvpn and if you're not a member of
nordvpn already that's shameful enough
but it's about to get even more shameful
because now they've added another layer
of security called threat protection
which protects you from malicious
websites downloads trackers intrusive
ads it's constantly on the lookout you
don't even need to connect to a vpn to
use it but it is an amazing next level
of protection that i highly recommend
that you use just flick the switch
you're protected obviously there's many
great reasons for using a vpn you've
probably heard this a million times but
i'm gonna say it again to protect
yourself and connect connected to public
wi-fi networks is a great example open
up the world wide web to actually be
world wide web and you can use websites
that are country restricted and dumb
stuff like that access different shows
but overall just protect yourself online
which is really really important people
are making money off your data let that
sink in not on my watch before i was
like i don't care if people use my they
make money
a lot of money
nerdvpn.com pewdiepie stop them they
have a huge discount for a two-year plan
and you get it one free additional month
with a 30 day money back guarantee so if
you want to try it and for some reason
which won't happen trust me you don't
want to use it that's nordvpn.com
pewdiepie check it out thank you nordvpn
great sponsor onward video caught you in
8k h uhd surround sound 16 gigs ram hdr
geforce rtx ti 80 texas intermittent
aaa duracell battery ultra power 100
target door compatible iphone one a5 the
1400 cable 100
one metro blanket compatible iphone 5 5
c5 and s6 hey hey
xoxo xoxon max gear
jesus christ oh that's better thank you
i want to die now you know who was
caught in 4k i was oh coursers died no
corpse died
listen
you don't have to do this
i have a child you do have two drills i
have a two child like i forgot about it
but hey listen i'll just stay here
and you just walk away you know i won't
tell i won't tell anyone i won't tell
anyone i swear i'll be back in in a few
minutes
still here okay i will be of course
thank you thank you so much i
i won't forget this
[Laughter]
this guy sure looks like he's selling
candy door to door but something
sinister is about to take place watch
what happens when the homeowner in
stockton california opens the door to
buy a box of candy out of nowhere three
guys burst into the house
it's a home invasion you can hear the
woman screaming in terror
the candyman takes off earlier that day
yeah
never buy candy from an old man i never
yeah i never seen a grown man sell candy
dorted everywhere but this time the
homeowner refused to open the door he
spoke to inside edition in a mask to
protect his identity he was very fidgety
yeah
fidgety it's interesting though because
yeah it doesn't really make sense why
would a guy come and sell candy at my
door right just be safe out there trust
your intuition guys if something seems
off tell him
ain't no need to be polite oh this is a
classic video of
a woman in lakewood california
yes catch that big employee who
allegedly stole her credit card number
listen to this
good how are you doing
so we got you on camera yesterday at
ralph's for 212 dollars so just know
that the cops are coming up here they
recorded everything you took a copy of
my car the other day on new year's day
you know what you did
right you know what you did right
are you so sorry your side
you took a copy of my card here
while you said you were going to go get
receipt paper
and they got your ass on camera
yesterday
okay
so i do know what you did right before i
press charges and everything on you
so what are you sorry about that you
took money from me and my kids what are
you sorry about i'm sorry that i took
money from you and your kids i'm tired
i'm sorry that you have to come up here
i'm sorry that this is inconvenient for
you
yeah she's acting like she's apologizing
to her teacher yes you're saying that
you're about to lose your job because
corporate knows is that what you're
sorry about too
all right let's go i'm sorry i am a good
child i still wear i'm you're a good
child hell no hell no
she plays soccer okay let it go she's
fine she's that's cool
she's 19 plays soccer all forgiven oh
oh oh
caught in 4k
mr beast copying someone else's comment
someone copied someone else's jokes this
is unheard of cancel him right now
hello
hola is that your feet
why do they have to do this everything
tick tock starts like that bro they're
not even caught in 4k she just shits
herself i've seen this
oh my god in the [ __ ] music i swear
these shorts and tick tocks are driving
me insane what do you know about
i don't know where he's what he want to
deny her and that's not fair to me
because i never cheated
i never cheated him if i had doubts
that this wasn't
i wouldn't even have the baby but i
loved him i loved him
did they make tv like this anymore all
right i need we need to bring it back
i mean i i really couldn't believe it
you know when she told me because
time difference ain't ain't nothing to
add enough to me you know what i'm
saying that baby wouldn't be anybody
really
really all right cause you go you're
gonna be on child support so it don't
need matter
what all right let's hear the result
most important
is the dna test yeah dna
i only think there's a container we're
gonna frame these results sentencing
your mama your baby mama everybody in
the family
in the case of four-month-old mariah
rafael
you are not
[Applause]
oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
oh she loves him now that's so crazy
[Music]
okay i'm satisfied i'm officially
satisfied caught in 4k cartoon 4k not
subscribing smashing like and i don't
know do whatever you want thanks for
watching see you next time